>> So today for Authors at Google SF, we'd
like to welcome Bob Gilbreath.
He is the Chief Marketing Strategist at Bridge
Worldwide, a WPP agency, and he's here to
speak about his new book "The Next Evolution
of Marketing: Connect with Your Customers
by Marketing with Meaning".
Just a little brief summary on it, he mentions
how the old interruptive model of marketing
no longer works.
Customers are tuning out.
They are no longer listening to these in your
face messages.
Instead, they're demanding meaning from brands
they buy from and the marketing that reaches
them.
In "The Next Evolution of Marketing", Bob
will unveil a new, revolutionary new approach
to business that fills the gaping voids left
in bottom lines when people start tuning out.
He'll describe the marketing revolution now
underway and the powerful forces driving it.
So with that, please welcome Bob Gilbreath
[applause]
Bob Gilbreath >> Thank you. Thanks for coming.
Those behind the bar, feel free to get within
view [laughs] .
I can serve your needs much better if I can
see ya but [laughs] thanks for having me.
This is really a great service you guys have,
both for authors like myself to come and visit,
but I think it's really neat that you can,
you can be here and learn from others that
are coming in.
I've been watching several of the Authors
at Google presentations actually over the
years and very, very impressed and would love
to do something similar back at our office
in Cincinnati.
Just a couple of things I want to talk about.
I think, I'm here for two things both: I've
got a book concept I think you might find
interesting but I'm also Head of Strategy
at one of the top 30 digital agencies here
in North America.
Again, part of WPP.
My background before joining Bridge, I was
Grant Manager at Proctor and Gamble and did
that for about six years.
Almost went to Yahoo instead of going to Proctor
in the late 90's and it was probably a pretty
good move at the time but always kind of had
digital in my blood and, and working as some,
both the kind of traditional brand management
stuff, I was also the digital geek in the
halls and always got a lot of those projects
so going to Bridge was kind of chance to kind
of do that full time and get my peers and
friends on the other side of the, the client
agency line to, to join me in the, the digital
revolution.
Quick points on Bridge: we're headquartered
in Cincinnati.
We've got about 270 people there now.
Slides a little bit dated.
We've also got a small office in New York
and opening an office soon in LA.
The thing we're probably most proud of is
being named one of the best Top 25 small businesses
to work for by the same people who do the
Fortune Magazine Most Admir--Best Companies
to Work for list and that's something that
really for us makes sure that we draw great
talent, keep them, and, and have them to continue
to develop.
We're part of WPP so I guess we're "frenemies"
with Google, whatever that means but we definitely
had some good, good relationships there.
We work with a lot of kind of major Fortune
100 clients, that's really our, our business
focus.
Heavy in the CPG with Proctor and Gamble,
retail with Kroeger, Luxottica, and also some
financial services; I know some of you here
represent that.
We work with Fifth Third Bank.
We also do some work for US Bank but they
don't like to know we're working on those
so...
We do a ton of brand work.
This is really kind of the heart of what we
are as an agency is being the digital agency
of record for several major brands ranging
from Luvs to Red Bull to Ingram Micro.
Again, heavy into CPG, healthcare, financial
services as well.
And the thing that I do in my job most of
the day is help my team and our clients with
the, the key questions that they're all asking
in the hallways right now which is where is
marketing going?
What do I do in digital of the fifty or sixty
different things that are possible, and even
down to the things like what's my social media,
social media strategy?
What is a little frustrating when you get
all those questions is that a lot of times
it's diving right down into the tactics, right?
So what exactly should I do?
And I think that what I want to share and
really the purpose of this book is to try
to get the entire industry really to, to raise
up a level and look at what is really the
right way to engage in marketing period.
If we were to look and start over of what
is marketing about, what is the right way
to approach that and that will help us get
to the right tactics, the right, the right
things that we actually do to bring those
strategies to life.
And about three years ago, I started thinking
about this, this concept and really kind of
started off with a very basic statement which
I think most people would agree with.
And that's that people don't like advertising,
right?
Okay, there's a few smiles and waves, and
nods there.
It's sad but true and again, I've worked in
marketing for a long time and an advertising
agency for a while.
It's sad to admit this but this is really
the first step of any, any change, right?
It's admitting your mistakes and what's wrong
with what you're doing today.
And if you look at advertising today, in many
cases it's irrelevant at best and can be offensive
at worst and if you take things like the erectile
dysfunction category, that we've all seen
the advertising for these and what's amazing
is that it's only about one percent of men
over age 40 suffer from this condition.
The other 99 percent of us -- I'm not bragging
by the way.
I'm sorry [laughs].
That's a little bit weird.
Anyhoo, I'm not 40 yet actually [laughs].
But it's irrelevant for most of the people
who are watching this and, and as a father
of two daughters, one 9 and one 7, it's really
also not fun when you're watching the Sunday
football game and, and, with the family and
see advertising for this and have your daughter
ask, "Daddy, what's ED?"
True story.
I have another friend who has a son who said,
"I think I may have ED, Mom".
So sometimes advertising, even when it's irrevelant,
irrelevant, can go too far.
And then we, as an industry overall, have
overwhelmed people with junk.
So we put ads on gas pumps, ads on turnstiles
at the Cincinnati Bengals Stadium, and even
in the Netherlands, ads on sheep in a field.
There's a sheep advertising network out there
that maybe Google can buy up and have some
revelant, relevant ads for us there.
But it's really getting a little bit out of
control and the model of this constantly finding
new ways to interrupt people is starting to
break down.
In many ways, digital has been that catalyst.
And if you look at it at its heart, it's that
its giving people new habits of how they consume
media and the freedom that they have to control
their experience.
One thing that's really interesting is that
people are watching, listening to, and, and
reading less ad supported media overall.
There was a study a couple of years ago that
said ad supported media consumption is actually
down in the past five years and that's continuing
today even as people seem to be consuming
more media than ever.
What's happening there is that people are
able to watch a DVD, maybe a whole season
of television on a DVD, instead of watching
it on traditional twenty minutes out of every
hour commercial supported television.
People loading enough songs and creating playlists
on their IPod's that you really don't have
a need for terrestrial or ad supported radio.
You've got your best hits right on hand, or
even things like video games where the sales
of Madden's annual franchise games keep going
up among young men and viewership of actual
live football is going down.
While there is some advertising in Madden,
it's more to just make the game look legitimate
versus actually adding to the experience.
And then of course we know the story of people
have freedom to skip or avoid advertising
in many ways.
Tivo, who I'm meeting with later today actually,
tools like BugMeNot allow you to get content
without registering, and AdBlock which about
six million people have now installed on Firefox,
that if you haven't tried it, it takes five
minutes to install and takes away all banner
ads that you see on websites.
And so once you start seeing that happen,
it's a pretty slippery slope to see that the
model is starting to fail and more banners
is not the answer.
We make a lot of banners for a lot of clients.
We make money.
My salary is paid by banners but I can tell
you right now that's not the future of where
marketing is going to go in digital.
We see things like MySpace, Facebook.
CPM's are horrible, responses are anemic.
The government is starting to track, crack
down on the targeting tools that we want to
use.
That again, there's no one out there protesting
to say let's allow advertisers to keep using
our personal data to serve better ads.
That's not going to happen because of the
industry relationship we have.
And then finally, when we do eye tracking
studies, we see that more and more people
learn where banners are and learn not to look
at them.
And so that's just another reality that we
have to face and figure out how to, how to
learn and migrate from there.
It's not just making the banner bigger, "So
here are a couple of the new sizes, the push
down, the XXL box."
You know again, even organizations like Tech
Cruncher are making fun of this who make money
off banner ads but the reality is what do
you do when people start ignoring these ads
too.
One of the things that is interesting is AOL's
new strategy.
One of the first things they did was cut out
a lot of the ad inventory to make their service
seem better.
Again, they're listening to their consumers
and that's the first step.
But that's not good news for, for advertisers
we work with.
So you take that model and you say, "Wow,
we just can't keep interrupting people. What
do we do instead?"
And I think if you start to look around, you
see that a new model is starting to form and
again, digital is actually the catalyst in
many ways.
Some of the best new marketing out there is
happening because of new digital tools that
we have.
Nike Plus for example.
Who's on Nike Plus?
Come on.
All right .
We got one, two way in the back there.
You want to say how many miles you guys have
or is that too personal?
[laughs]
I got on this about a year and half ago really
to frankly learn what the marketing hype was
about and found it to be an incredible service
where it's helping me track my runs, improve
my distance, improve my times, do challenges
with friends.
It's really somewhere between a product and
service and marketing.
It's, it's hard to tell but regardless, it's
working very well for Nike.
They say 30 percent of the users of Nike Plus
return more than once per week and in the
first year that they launched this, they said
that it was responsible for an eight percent
increase in profits.
And so now Nike as an entire company has really
moving its marketing model toward creating
digital services.
In basketball, they've got training videos
online by actual NBA trainers and Europe,
they have a special shoe that you buy and
when you buy it, you get access to a IPhone
app that you can bring out to the practice
field and get real tips and training regimens
from, from the pros.
Southwest Airlines is another great digital
example of adding value through marketing.
Their tool called Ding actually lets people
find - there's a lot of people who will use
Southwest to fly between key cities.
Say they've got family in Houston and they
live in San Antonio.
If that price -- fare price gets down to a
certain level they'll go any weekend and so
this Ding tool allows people to, to call out
the flights that they're interested in, what
fares are the magic price points for them.
And then when those fares hit, 'ding'.
You hear it in your inbox – sorry -- on
your desktop and you can buy a fare right
there off the spot and some of the results
on this one, 10 million site visits through
Ding just in the third quarter of last year
and it's about four years in now.
The, the data that they are sharing at least
so far as the second year end they got 150
million in revenue from this tool -- so incredible.
Incredible service there and it's marketing
that people enjoy.
Kraft Foods is another one.
Kraft has been a leader in really using digital
to provide services for people.
You've probably seen kraftfoods.com.
They've got a great website with recipes of
every type.
They've added cooking videos and they've now
-- they've gotten into IPhone apps with a
tool called IFood.
Incredible success for them so far.
They actually got featured in ITunes and they're
selling it for 99 cents.
They felt like it was so valuable that they
needed to price it at a certain point to communicate
the value to buyers of it.
And they said that they hit their three year
download goal in just a matter of weeks.
I think in "Advertising Age" last week, they
announced that they are doing a 2.0 with more
services, more revenue opportunities which
means it's definitely working for them.
And you guys are doing this as well, something
definitely interesting.
If you look at the value of Google, maybe
the first company that's created a, a big
sizable business off of creating marketing
that people want to see with Google
AdWords.
Again, Bob Garfield said it best that consumers
may not care much for commercials but they
do want to learn a lot about the information
that brands have and they're actively seeking
that and you are helping them find that, and
that really kind of gets to what this concept
is all about.
We call it Marketing with Meaning and really
we think there's two elements of what is meaningful
marketing and what is really gonna succeed
today and increasingly going forward.
The first is it's marketing that people choose
to engage with, and if you think about that
carefully, I mean for old time marketers like
myself, we're used to buying eyeballs, right?
Impressions by the thousand.
This is shifting that and saying what it's
really about is how many people choose to
engage with the marketing that you've created.
It's a much smaller number but it's actually
a much higher chance of getting sales at a
high rate from people once they're actually
saying I want to be a part of the marketing
that you're creating.
And then the second piece is it's creating
marketing that itself improves people's lives.
Again, it's really hard for traditional advertisers
to kind of think this way especially marketing
that, that may not have the force, you may
not force to buy the product or service itself.
I know when I worked at Proctor and Gamble,
I worked on new formulas with Tide, new products
like Mr. Clean Magic Eraser.
I loved getting up in the morning and knowing
that I was creating products that people loved
and they told me at focus groups; they wrote
emails.
It was, it was great but then I would go work
on a commercial where I'd try to squeeze in,
on Tide we called it the "Into the Light"
shot where Mom going by her television set
with the commercial playing would get some
unconscious symbolism of whiteness linked
to the brand and we spent hours and hours
trying to perfect those interruptions so we
could somehow get there.
This is about actually creating the marketing
that improves people's lives so frankly a
lot of the work we do as marketers and advertisers
is more valuable to us as part of the equation
that comes through here.
One of things that we've done and a couple
of things in the book as well; I think tools
we use in our company, one of the things is
really where do you start?
What do you do that's meaningful for your
brand and, and your consumers and one very
simple way of looking at it kind of – is
come -- comes from "Maslow's Hierarchy of
Needs" and you probably remember this from
Sociology 101.
It's about 50 years old, this model, but it's
still the best way to kind of understand what
are people's need and then when -- what do
they satisfy next once they've, they've met
those needs.
It starts off with things like food and shelter
and water.
Then you go to levels like friendship and
family.
And then finally at the top is self actualization
around how do I improve myself, my family,
and the world around me.
We've created something similar we call the
"Hierarchy of Meaningful Marketing" which
is one way to help brands really come up with
those ideas.
The very basic level is solution and so this
is things like give me services, information,
and incentives that are helpful.
This is that bar; to be meaningful you've
at least got to add value in that way.
The lowly coupon is a great example of meaningful
marketing.
This is, for decades, people have gone to
their Sunday papers to look for advertising
in the form of the Sunday coupon.
They learn about what's new; they get discounts
on purchases they're thinking about buying.
And the problem though is that this is a medium
that's gone pretty old and hasn't been updated
in a while.
A project we got to work on with two of our
clients, Proctor and Gamble and Kroger, was
P&G E-Saver and this is a -- really the first
for, for both -- an online coupon linked to
that Sunday paper.
What you could do is register on the site,
register your Kroger shopper card and then
every week you can see which coupons are coming
out.
You don't have to buy the newspaper. You check
off the ones that you're interested in and
then when you buy the products at the store,
you get the credit automatically put on the
end of your grocery bill so this is a great
win-win.
Newspaper circulations have declined so it
helps the marketers, helps the consumers because
it's more convenient.
Women and moms are starting to plan their
shopping trips online, first and foremost.
The results have been really great.
They had a hundred thousand people register
for this in the first month, well north of
that today and we're seeing things like higher
shopper card registration, personalization
that we've tested has become very successful,
people opening the emails more, redeeming
the coupons more really at a rate that's unseen
in, in traditional Sunday coupons so great,
great stuff there.
Anyone use the Domino's Pizza Tracker lately?
Tons of people are using it.
This is really interesting and it was kind
of a surprise story but it shows a lot of
different opportunities for brands to just
provide information about the products that
they're selling, or in this case delivering.
About a year ago, Dominos actually had a problem
which is people will call in frequently after
they've ordered their pizza but before the
thirty minutes is up to see where it is, and
really some of that is that we've become use
to this "Where's my order? Where's my, where's
my delivery?"
We get our UPS packages; we track the steps
along the way and Dominos was having their
phone lines tied up with people checking on
the progress of their pizza.
So they launched this Pizza Tracker online
that has a – it's quasi real, quasi simulated
stages of where the pizza is depending on
when you ordered it and now people are going
there.
When it was first launched around the Super
Bowl last year, a lot of people in the industry
laughed at and said, "Who wants to check their
pizza?"
Well, in the first two months, a million people
were silly enough to do that and that was
only in half the stores that was rolled out
at that time.
At this point, it's been a huge success for
Dominos.
On-liners are now 28 percent of their sales,
75 percent of those people are using the Pizza
Tracker, and they've now put the Pizza Tracker
in an IPhone app, on Facebook, and more tools
coming along the way so that silliness is
doing very well for them.
And it's inspired a lot of other companies
to get into things like there's an egg company
where you can track which farm your egg came
from based on a code that's printed on the
egg.
Dole bananas have a SKU where you can track
which farm around the world the bananas came
from.
People love the information about the products
that they're, they're buying and I spotted
this this morning.
Actually a friend of mine called knowing I
was coming here but some of the things that
you're doing at Google I think have a lot
of opportunity to provide that information
that people are looking for.
I think this was announced yesterday at the
big meeting you guys had down at the headquarters,
Search by Site with Google Goggles, where
you could say hold up your IPhone over a wine
label and then automatically get some information
about that product right there.
So tons of opportunity.
People do want this information and then,
in this case, they want it at the wine store.
They're not going to go home and boot up their
laptop to get the information they need so
a great use of mobile to provide info.
The second level we call connection and so
this is really about that, that next step.
How do you create experiences that people
can share with others?
One of the challenges we had at our agency
a little over a year ago was with launching
a new product from Healthy Choice, which is
owned by Con Agra Foods.
Healthy Choice has been known for years as
really the product for if you've got health
issues and you need things that are a little
bit better for you, a little bit lower sodium
or less fat.
It's been a great market over the years but
it's been limited and kind of too much niche
– really wanted as -- the brand really
wanted to get to a younger audience.
The first step they took was to make better
products that are, are better taste, more
convenient, which they've done some great
work on there.
But they needed to explain these products
were available to a group of thirties and
forty somethings that have really not spent
much time thinking about Healthy Choice in
the past couple years.
We did some research and we really found out
that sixty percent of our target audience
is in offices and they're eating lunch at
their desks.
We thought that there really was an opportunity
there.
We dug a little further in that and we found
at that time when they're having lunch at
their desk is me time, right?
They're not doing work emails then or responding.
They're checking out their personal email
accounts maybe; they're checking what's new
with their Facebook updates, or looking at
things like viral videos.
And one of the guys on our team said that
lunch time is the new prime time.
And so we created this pretty cool entertaining
experience around Healthy Choice and I'll
show this quick video to describe it.
[video plays in background]
[music on video]
>> Video Narrator: "Working Lunch" is the
first ever live improve web series directed
by the audience.
Fresh Mixers gave office workers a convenient
to mix fresh ingredients into a tasty meal.
"Working Lunch" gave them a fun way to create
fresh, live improve comedy from the comfort
of their cubes.
The audience was in control from the start,
influencing the action in real time every
step of the way.
It was the digital equivalent of shouting
out a suggestion in a comedy club.
And it led to some crazy stuff.
In all, 16 original episodes were streamed
across 3 time zones every day during the lunch
hour.
[music on video]
"Working Lunch" and Fresh Mixers were a hit,
serving nearly 3 million live video streams.
"Working Lunch" – user powered comedy served
fresh at your desk.
Now that's fresh.
[music on video]
>> Bob Gilbreath: So, pretty fun stuff and
it drove the results for the business as well.
We've had -- now had over 5 million views
of the videos that we served up there and
had a very successful launch of their Cafe
Steamers products there.
What's also really great about this story
is it was the first kind of big digital led
idea that the company, Con Agra, had done
and now that we saw some success there and
made it happen, it's gotten the whole company
really pumped up of doing more and kind of
take it to next level on, on future initiatives.
Any time you personalize a product, this is
meaningful marketing that I think really does
a good job on hitting on that idea of connections.
My M&M's probably the best at this.
They've been doing it for five or six years
now.
It started off you could just type a simple
message, a few words and pick out the color
M&M's that you wanted, and they've now continued
to evolve that to where you can have sport
teams on there; you can have pictures uploaded.
It's really, really great and any time you're
having consumers make the brand their own,
that's a much, much deeper connection that
lasts a lot longer than just that "Into the
White" shot of whiteness equity point that
you may get with a traditional commercial.
M&M's, again, you think about -- used to be
fifty cents at the checkout counter was what
they look at for a sale.
With this product, it's a 7 ounce pack for
12.99, minimum of three packs plus shipping
and handling so it goes from being a fifty
cent item into a fifty dollar brand experience.
Better experience for the consumer, much more
profitable for M&M's.
And they said that this line has really revitalized
the entire brand and they are now taking it
to their other products like Dove candy for
example.
I wanted to just throw an example of a non-digital
social media story in here too.
One of my favorite examples of really kind
of long term meaningful marketing is what
the Mount Gay Rum brand has done with its
red hats.
I'm not sure if there's any sailors out there
but this is a premium rum brand that's actually
been around for three hundred years from Barbados
and several years ago they started sponsoring
regattas and if you actually participate,
if you're sailing in this regatta, you get
a commemorative hat from Mount Gay Rum with
the name of the regatta across the top sewn
in.
And these hats have become incredible collector's
items for people, like that proof that you've
been in the race.
And what it's used as is that people will
be walking around in an airport or on a beach
with one of these hats on and other sailors
will come up to them out of the blue and strike
up a conversation about the race itself, what
boat do you sail, and that type of thing.
And so these rum hat wearers go out in public
wearing the hat, knowing that it'll help them
connect with other people.
And so great example of a kind of social media
without digital that shows that people can
connect over brands with the simple investment
of a red hat.
Again, I want to throw a good Google example
in there.
What you all are doing with celebrating events,
holidays, special moments like Sesame Street's
40th Anniversary; this is meaningful marketing
of Google.
This is part of the reason that your company
continues to be the number one most valuable
brand in the world without doing a 100 million
dollar glitzy advertising campaign like some
of your competitors, Yahoo and AOL, are doing
right now.
Makes -- making the everyday fun, making it
meaningful, that's really what it's all about
and sometimes it's just these little things
that, that can have a huge impact.
Speaking of little things, I want to share
this.
Anyone clicked on this banner ad in the past
couple of months?
Would you click it? We actually had a challenge
on…
The Pringles brand is one of our clients;
they had gone through a process where they
really wanted to restructure the brand and
really kind of take a new look of what was
their brand purpose; why does the brand exist.
This is something that, that their former
Chief Marketing Officer, Jim Stengel, really
led for the company and they've continued
to, to push that from there.
Pringles came up with a new brand purpose
which is words to the effect of Pringles exist
to create moments of spontaneous fun.
And one of the first pieces of work that,
that we got under that new brand purpose was
the lowly banner ad, right?
I just ended up talking a lot of bad things
about banner ads but our team took that on
and said, "Okay, how can we – very simple,
brief – how can we create spontaneous fun
through a normal banner ad?"
And they came up with this concept which is
really daring.
It's weird, it's odd, and frankly daring people
to click and when you do start clicking, like
I will right now.
[pause]
So each one of these is one of 97 total clicks
here.
[pause]
But check it out, check it out.
Google 'Pringles Banner' and you'll go right
to our staging server.
We knew this was successful when actually
we had it on staging and it somehow leaked
to the outside public and within about three
days, we had three hundred thousand
people go through this banner ad on our website
and twenty percent of them clicked all the
way to the end which is 97 frames if you're,
you're wondering.
And what really made us feel good was seeing
this listed, listed on on Buzz Feed.
Even the critics at FARK raved about this.
We knew that we had something that, that was
very powerful when people are saying 'best
banner ad ever', 'thanks for making my day',
and then importantly, 'I'm going to go rush
out and buy some Pringles this weekend because
you made me have such a great time'.
For us in the agency business, we also love
it because you can still win can advertising
awards for it.
We got a Gold Lion in June and this was the
first Gold Lion in the cyber category, or
digital category, that Proctor and Gamble
had ever won so even the lowly banner ad;
you can do some fun stuff with.
In the final level, we call it achievement
so this is again mirroring Maslow: help me
improve myself, my family, and the world around
me.
A program we created that we've been running
for five years, Diabetes Control for Life.
We saw a real opportunity for people who were
newly diagnosed with diabetes.
They go in, the doctor tells them they've
got a disease that they'll probably have for
their life, that they've got to change their
eating habits, and they've got to exercise
more and twenty minutes later, they're ushered
out and are on their own and we found a real
opportunity to provide them kind of the coaching
and guidance and tools that they needed to
make health habit change and with this program,
the centerpiece is a 24 week meal and fitness
planner that actually has clinical data that
shows that people's A1C levels, which is a
key determent of the diseases progression,
go down and their weight is going down and
they're saying they're feeling better.
And so we've got great results for improving
their lives but then we also have some great
data that shows participants in the program
are buying three times more Abbott products
here in the diabetes category so that's again
a tremendous win- win for them.
Something I also want to point out that just
popped up for me this week that I blogged
about, Facebook is really helping people create
causes and I got an email.
My birthday is coming up in another week or
so and got this message from Facebook saying
we know your birthday is coming up and they
also know that everyone on my Facebook list
is going to be seeing that.
This year why don't you help support a charity?
So with this pretty simple tool, in about
five minutes, you say why you're going to
donate and you can pick the charity that you're
interested in donating to.
It's really early; check it out.
I think it's pretty interesting but it's,
it's neat how they kind of take that personal
thing that we all experience every year and
turn it from being something that's dreaded
even and turning it into something positive
that you can share with your, your friends'
network.
So really cool stuff there.
I want to interrupt with just some other things
that we've been thinking about lately, about
this concept and, and the clients that we're
speaking with.
One is that I think that we're always asked
the question and we were always out there
saying, "What's new? What's my Twitter strategy?
What do I do in social media? Is this the
year of mobile?"
There's also a lot of those questions about
the tactics that are, are up and coming and
one of things I think that's really easy is
to, to look through new media through this
lens of meaningful marketing and in many ways,
I think that we're leapfrogging the interruptive
stage and going right to the meaning stage
in our industry and , that's really -- if
you look at that idea of leap frog technology,
it's, it's mainly used when you talk about
in China -- they're not putting in telephone
poles like we had in our country.
They're going straight to the best technology;
they're going straight to cell towers.
In certain other countries, they're not putting
in coal plants; they're going straight to
solar cells.
So if you think about that in a new media,
I think we're already seeing mobile, for example,
leap frog the interruptive stage, the tiny
little banner stage, and going right to things
like apps.
And I know if we look -- as I look across
some of our clients and others out there,
it's tough to get this data but I'd be willing
to bet that brands are already spending more
money on added value apps than they are on
regular mobile media.
I think that's something that brands are really
starting to get excited about.
Charmin is one of our clients; they have a
great app called "Sit or Squat" that helps
you find bathrooms, public restrooms, when
you're in need.
I mean, believe me, it's the most innovative
stuff since Mr. Whipple came on the scene.
But this little app is something that's getting
a Charmin brand, again, total paper brand,
in the marketing pages and having people excited
about it.
And having a great experience with this app,
you may become a Charmin fan for life versus
kind of losing favor every couple of years
and needing a commercial, friendly commercial
reminder.
Gaming is another area where as soon as - especially
through things like XBox Live, people have
been looking for how do we put another banner,
how do we put some kind of ad message into
games?
Here you can see one example I pulled from
my Guitar Hero playing; you can barely see
it on the fake stage of Guitar Hero but that's
an ad for Microsoft Sync, in car audio product.
Here you can see an ad for Diesel on a, on
a racing game. I think already that's, that's
not getting the mass support that a lot of
people and entrepreneurs would hope it would
but what is seeing a lot of success is when
you add value to the gamers' experience.
Best Buy, for example, partnered with Rock
Band to -- on the re-release of the album
"Ten"; they provided three free songs for
Pearl Jam songs you could play on your Rock
Band game.
So that was a great promotion that was actually
adding value.
Universal Studios launching the movie "Tropic
Thunder" partnered with Tom Clancy's Red Cell
Vegas game, First Person Shooter, to create
a whole new level that you could play in kind
of a scavenger hunt for the game.
So again, they're adding more content to the
game experience and that helped them get a
lot of buzz for their opening weekend which
was critical.
One last thing I want to hit on is again,
our clients, a, a lot of mass marketers that
for years have been about hitting tens of
millions of consumers' eyeballs a year and
hoping a small percentage of them buys the
products.
When we talk about digital, when we talk about
what to do in the world where that kind of
traditional interruptive model is falling
apart, what we constantly hear back -- and
I'm sure a lot of you have heard it as well
-- is what about scale?
How do I get scale?
How do I get those tens of millions of people
to pay attention to my message?
And I think the watch out here is that A)
scale is already going away.
It's very, very hard even with an interruption
to hit that many people.
They're not -- folks are tuning out of traditional
advertising or splintering it along five hundred
channels but I think there's a really different
opportunity to have a more focused kind of
relationship marketing experience with a much
smaller group of people and again being something
that's meaningful marketing; you can keep
them for life and get them to buy a lot more
of your products than just finding a very
weak interruption.
And one piece of evidence that I see on that
is that if you look at Nike Plus kind of,
something I mentioned earlier, it's a global
tool.
It's been around for four years now; it's
a big focus of Nike's marketing efforts.
It only has about 1.5 million people using
it, who have ever used it, around the world
and if you dig even deeper, it's only about
250,000 people who have run or walked at least
one hundred miles.
That's not a lot -- I mean that's kind of
the basics and so you look at this huge tool
that's getting a lot of buzz is really only
focusing on a couple hundred thousand people.
That's hard for a traditional market to understand
but Nike is seeing the results and that's
why they're shifting this model. They're seeing
that, "Wow, we can get those 250,000 people
and more and get them to spend a couple hundred
dollars with us every year versus getting
some tiny fraction to remember to buy our
shoes once every five years''.
So that's really kind of shifting the model
right there as well.
I do have one extra last thing I wanted, I
wanted to bring up because it was actually
a conversation we had at our WPP offices with
some folks from Google a couple of weeks ago
and this question of "Are GRP's really the
answer? Is that gross rating point the number
of eyeballs?"
There's a lot of people in the digital marketing
industry that say, "You know what? We're not
getting the growth we need. Consumers are
still not spending enough on digital so let's
just put everything we do into the impression,
cost per thousand model."
Jeff Ramsey, one of the, the, the top data
guys in the industry for a while, recently
said this and quoted someone who said, "You'll
never see P&G and Unilever and those guys
spending online unless we give them reach
frequency and GRP's. Their entire business
model is based on that."
And we actually had a debate.
Dennis Woodside was with us a couple of weeks
ago talking about a new tool where it was
kind of like a click to play a video from
a brand and the discussion we had is that
what do you charge for that, right?
So in the CPM type model, it's twenty dollars
for every thousand people.
So that's maybe only a penny or less per view
on a traditional ad on television in primetime.
But what do you charge, what are marketers
willing to pay for someone who says, "I want
to see your ad. I want to click on it."
So that's one of the things we've got to struggle
with as an industry and I think it's much
better for us to start spending our time figuring
out what's the value of that engaged choice
for consumer than figuring out how do we take
that great experience there and dumb it down
and price it down to the level of lowest common
denominator with the GRP.
So some stuff we got to figure out.
The final thoughts I just want to say, I mean
we'll get some books out to you guys and definitely
follow up with me if you, you don't have enough
and, and I'm happy to send some out.
You guys are great thought leaders and the
kind of people that we want spreading this,
this word.
But the last thing I'd say is that when you
go back to the meeting here today, when you're
talking with brands, I think one really useful
tool to think about is to just ask yourself
the questions, "Will people choose to engage
with my marketing? Is my marketing itself
adding value to peoples' lives? And then frankly,
is this the kind of work that's meaningful
to me?"
And I think when we hit all three of those,
we're going to have a lot of great sales for
our clients and we're going to have a much
more enjoyable every day experience when we
get up in the morning too.
So the book is out.
I've got a website, marketingwithmeaning.com,
where I've got three blog posts a week.
For financial services folks, I've got a lot
of banking examples and stories in there.
Also got a Twitter feed that I update pretty
frequently too and with the book.
There's an IPhone app that goes along with
that where I've kind of got links to all the
examples used in the book which are about
five hundred to go see them online too.
So we got like ten minutes left.
Would love to take any questions. The tougher,
the better. Yeah?
>> So I guess I'm curious what's new?
With all due respect, I understand what you're
saying about this really new evolution, marketing
with meaning makes sense.
I'm just trying to capture like what's the
summary of what you are trying to say?
[inaudible]
Bob Gilbreath >> Right. Well, I think - so
the question for those, if you can't hear
it in different cities, is what's new about
this and I think there has been some talk
in the past of other concepts from… another
group calls Brand Utility.
There's another person out there that, that
says marketing a service.
Whatever buzz word we want to use is fine.
I think what I've really tried to do in the
book is give – it's a guide for the traditional
marketers that see a lot of cool new stuff
and tactics and know they need to get on digital
but they're not sure how.
And what they need is a real, a different
way of looking of what is the function of
marketing to then be able to understand what's
the right way to work in digital, what's the
right way to deliver on television, what's
the right way to do events or promotions.
And so the book itself, about the first half,
I kind of talk about just the overall concept
and then the second half I've got really a
step by step methodology for how do you set
great business objectives, how do you get
good insights, how do you create a strategy
around meaningful marketing, how do you measure,
how do you follow up, tips and experiences
I've had both on the client side of Proctor
as well as the agency side
working with a lot of big companies on the
mistakes to look out for.
So this is really getting at, and we were
just talking earlier, the ideas are out there,
the future is here -- it's unevenly distributed
and it's only distributed where organizations
have said how do I shift my entire way of
looking at marketing so I think that's really
what's new there, not the tactics but the
overall approach.
Yeah?
>> You've offered examples of like the apps,
the M&M's, the personalization website.
What would your advice be for the resourceful
trained SMV's that are almost working?
Bob Gilbreath >> For example, what are some
of the other companies? Small businesses?
>> Yeah.
Bob Gilbreath >> Yeah.
>>What people can do if they don't have money
for a program?
Bob Gilbreath >> Sure. Right.
Basically, what I think is really interesting
is especially with some of the social media
tools, it's allowing people to do, small business
to do things that they were never able to
do before and what's great about a small business
is often they have more time than they do
have money and they often know their customers
very well.
So using some social media tools, again not
just for its own sake or we need to get on
the bandwagon, but looking strategically as
what's a, what's a business objective you
have, what's an insight about your customer
base, and then what are some things maybe
we can do to hit on those to add value and
get higher sales.
One very basic one that I love is there's
a little deli by our office that has a Facebook
account that they basically focus on updating
their special every day at about 11 o'clock
so the business objective there is get more
people to come in more often.
The insight is about 11 o'clock you start
thinking about where you are going to go and
if you got that, for me it's the Buffalo Chicken
Sandwich.
If that's available, I'm at that deli every
time and by using Facebook, you're also able
to coordinate and message friends in the office
and say, "Hey, let's go out together. They're
having the special."
So their word of mouth -- they've told me
that they see sales increase since they started
doing that program.
You know, something that's very basic and
simple.
I think other ways, what you can do is again
focus on what that problem is.
Get some experimental budget money, help companies
set up a test and get some real data in.
>> Bob, I'd love to hear your thoughts on
where you think our products fit in with some
of your strategies because I see something
like AdWords speaking to
engagement in some senses and particularly
for a lot of our director's thoughts advertise
their focus on engagement but yet we've acquired
double
click and the big bat on display at the end
of advertising which may be opposition to
some of your thoughts.
How do you see our products fitting in?
Bob Gilbreath >> Yeah, I mean I think that
the better way to think about it -- what I
would encourage for all these products and
a lot of the traditional media is not going
to go away either so print is gonna continue,
radio is gonna continue, television is gonna
to continue and I think that the opportunities
are how do you twist it into really what the
strategy of how you use it in the creative
as well.
So while I said a lot of bad things about
banner ads, we love doing banners that actually
allow people to get deeper information, video,
into the banner itself so things like when
we say -- offer a sample through a banner
ad, we get incredible engagement rates.
Ten percent plus people choosing to hover
over that and spend thirty seconds, forty
seconds into that ad; so that's really where
I would see it.
And frankly the reality is that a lot of traditional
brand folks will say "I don't click on banners"
and so one of the answers to that is, "Well,
this is not really a banner. This is an experience;
this is a kind of a portal to where they can
get information that they desire without having
to leave the website that they're on today."
So anytime that we've seen that more rich
media that has added value, not just clever
annoyance or takeovers, that's where we see
really great results, and I think AdWords
– to me that is a core, arguably the first
real marketing company that is hitting on
marketing with meaning, where I'm searching
and I'm going to find things.
A lot of times what the advertiser is paying
for is useful and it's a win-win- win for
all three.
>> What do you see as the ideal balance between
a meaningful ad and a humorous ad?
I think we are so used to seeing beer commercials
and also viral videos where they are focused
on humor but the meaning could be lost but
then again, you don't have an aging advertising
exec that's not going to get any sort of [inaudible]
so the truth is out there.
Bob Gilbreath >> Yeah, I mean that's a really
tricky one.
Like one of the, one of the temptations would
be to say, "Hey, all you need to do in your
television commercial is make it cute or funny
and done deal. We got meaningful marketing
now."
There's certainly occasions where we all have
our favorite commercials that, that make us
laugh and we want to see again.
Maybe we want to go on YouTube and send it
to friends afterwards.
I think this is really though thinking of,
of first and foremost, about things like how
do we get something that's worthy of people
choosing to see it on YouTube and oh by the
way, we'll, we'll play it on a -- during the
Super Bowl or over the weekend games as well.
I think it's a little bit of a different way
of looking at it versus "hey we got thirty
seconds to fill. What do we do?"
We've got this time and so I think that if
you start looking at it in that way, it will
encourage creatives at agencies and other
places to start thinking more and
again giving a richer palace.
One of the problems with the traditional 30
second ad is it's only 30 seconds or maybe
a minute so creatively, that's a tough box
to break out of.
So that's something there that I think is
an opportunity for thinking first how can
we create something that's fun and interesting
and then second about traditional television.
Does that answer your question?
>> Yeah.
Bob Gilbreath >> Okay.
Someone was kind of ducking around there.
Yeah?
>> I'm curious to hear what your thoughts
are on some mistakes that you've seen against
the traditional advertisers trying to dip
their toes into digital?
Bob Gilbreath >> Tons of mistakes out there
and sadly in traditional organizations when
the mistakes happen often, that can be the
end of someone's career or the idea of experimenting.
I do try to talk about some examples that
I've seen, both in the industry and personal
experience in the book.
One of the -- I think the most interesting
ones is what Dr. Pepper did with their new
– I'm forgetting the name -- Guns and Roses
album.
Did anyone see that?
Where they said if the album finally comes
out after ten years of hype by the end of
2008, they'll give everybody in the country
a free Dr. Pepper and Axl Rose actually got
the album off in November and to fulfill that
obligation, they put a website up for just
24 hours for people to fill out the request
form and it crashed.
It was impossible to log on, a lot of negative
buzz on Twitter, other places online and they
came back and said, "Okay, we'll keep it open
for another half a day."
Again, you couldn't get through.
I tried about 25 times myself and people came
away with a pretty poor experience which -- where
it should have been the height of Dr. Pepper,
right?
So they focused on a piece of pop culture
-- people aren't really thinking about Dr.
Pepper.
They had a grand slam -- even Axl Rose was
excited about it and said, "Yep, we're happy",
even though he didn't get paid.
And for them to drop the ball on the execution,
that was really a negative there so that's
one of the things that a good agency will
help make sure that you've got extra server
capacity, put in a cloud or whatever but really
knowing that you got to fulfill your obligation.
I think another example that hits every year
and it's going on right now is the "Elf Yourself"
program from who knows where?
What brand does "Elf Yourself"?
Raise your hand if you think it's Staples.
Raise your hand if you think it's Office Max.
Raise your hand if you think it's Office Depot.
Okay, so there's no consensus, right?
It's Office Max, I think.
They've done it for four years and a huge
amount of people going through the program
but they've done nothing to actually to link
the brand to the program or to try and get
traffic into the stores at this important
time of year.
Now they've said, "Well, it just helps our
equity and we don't care about getting sales",
as crazy as that sounds but I think there
could have been a lot of opportunities for
again, thinking how could we be more meaningful
and then how do we handle the business objective
of getting people into the store.
They could have done something like once you
do your Jib Jab, you can hit a button and
go get a printout of your picture at the local
Office Max store, right?
So maybe something like that would get the
tens of millions of people who are playing
with this to go into the store and pick up
their free picture and then buy some, some
other gear that they need too.
So something simple like that I think could
have done a lot better.
So making sure you keep your eyes on what's
the business objective -- how are
we getting in your lives is still important.
Anybody else?
[Pause]
Great.
Thanks very much.
Appreciate it.
[applause]